das war er unter anderem ihre idee dass
sich die partei verjüngt hätten sie
gedacht dass die das noch schlechter
machen als sie
[Musik]
die grünen wo früher ernsthaft
diskutiert wurde heißt es heute jetzt
hier die demokratische bewegung in der
ukraine nicht legitimiert wo früher
farbbeutel auf den vorstand geschmissen
wurde wirft man heute nur noch mit
äpfeln sie lieben sich jetzt alle so als
würden hier lauter schmetterlinge
drüberfliegen und seine lieben und wie
ist das denn jetzt gekommen
ja ich weiß es auch nicht nur einen
antrag beschlossen im leben steht dass
wir uns alle lieb haben
das wird bei etwa schlossen ja was für
eine spießige lillifee lifestyle scheiße
wird echtzeit dass ich hier mal wieder
für ein bisschen zoff sorgen
der hof weiter wie tief muss eine partei
sinken wenn sie sich das comeback von
jürgen trittin wünscht niemand wünscht
sich das comeback von jürgen trittin
nicht mehr jürgen trittin wunsch dass
sich wieso reden sie noch mit jedem
dahergelaufenen komiker weil ich sie mag
dann ist verständlich meinte inhope
weiter
er hat sie mir sie sagen ja jürgen
trittin verdienste liegen in der
vergangenheit wann können wir mit ihren
verdiensten rechnen foto 242 mir aus dem
shop lädt die adserver du mehr wirklich
kein wort das war er unter anderem ihre
idee dass sich die partei verjüngt
hätten sie gedacht dass die das noch
schlechter machen als sie
also erstens habe ich das nicht schlecht
immer und die jungen sind durchaus auch
biologisch erfahren
quatsch blödsinn ja aber ekelt es sie
nicht manchmal auch an dass ihr
aktueller wirtschaftskurs wahrscheinlich
sogar joschka fischer irgendwie gefallen
würde
das macht ja gar nicht selber auch
grüner wie konnte es passieren dass aus
der sympathischen dagegen-partei die
profillose ich mach's mit jedem partei
wurde
also das ist so eine unterstellung dass
das so wäre ja aber mit wir machen das
nicht weil ich nicht will
irgendwie klappt doch nicht aber eine
idee habe ich noch werden sie den
parteivorsitz wieder übernehmen
ich bin ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz
happy mit dem was ich jetzt mache und
auch mit der pest mit dem personal das
jetzt verteiler sitzt macht okay sie
wird den parteivorsitz nicht übernehmen
und mit zumindest dieser guten nachricht
gebe ich zurück an studien
[Applaus]
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liebst -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]